-Our next guest is a filmmaker
whose new documentary series
"Unprecedented" is streaming on
Discovery+.
Let's take a look.
-The shot is beautiful, sir.
-Okay.
Can we get the orange out,
please?
Is that possible?
It's very orangey.
I don't know why that is.
-Please welcome to the show
Alex Holder, everybody.
♪♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
Thank you so much
for being here.
-It's a pleasure.
-So, you have made a few
documentary films before,
and then you made this series,
which is -- Basically, you were
with the Trump family,
the Trump campaign
before the election
all the way up to January 6th.
-Yeah.
-And I think one of the things
people have been taken with,
who have watched this, is
the amount of access you got
to the Trump family.
Why do you think it is that they
agreed to it, and what were
the secrets you used to get them
to make that decision?
-I mean, so I was originally
introduced to them,
and then I think they were
really confident
they were going to win
the election.
So here was a guy with a funny
accent that was going to
showcase them winning
the 2020 election.
Also, I didn't really have any
skin in the game politically,
so why not, here's a guy
going to film us.
I don't think they planned
the inevitable outcome,
at least I didn't expect it,
so yeah.
-And you got to film in
the White House, obviously.
What was it like?
I would imagine no matter who
the president is, there are
some stresses involved with
going and setting up
a film shoot in the White House.
-So, it was a remarkable
experience.
I mean, to go inside, we take
out all the equipment,
the dogs come out, sniff
everything, eventually we go
inside to the residence
of the White House.
This is the diplomatic reception
room.
And none of the crew had ever
really filmed
in the White House before.
And so we didn't know what
the protocol was.
So, there's a few White House
ushers that are inside,
and I start talking to
one of them.
In the middle of the
conversation, he just stops
talking and he looked like he
was about to have a stroke.
I mean, literally,
his eyes popped out.
It was just, like,
suspended animation.
So I was like,
"What's going on?"
And, basically, Michael,
my director of photography,
had moved a chair, and the guy
was like mouthing wordlessly,
like -- like, "You literally
can't do this,"
and eventually he managed to get
his words together.
And Michael -- he goes,
"You can't move that chair."
So Michael actually puts the
chair back, and he's like,
"No, no, no,
stop moving the chair.
That chair is
Abraham Lincoln's chair.
I mean,
it was absolutely insane.
I mean, just completely mad.
[ Laughter ]
-Well, that's Lincoln's fault
for leaving it there.
-Exactly. Right. Exactly.
[ Laughter ]
-You know, at some point,
you know?
I'm pretty sure
he has his own bedroom.
They could put it in there.
[ Laughter ]
So, one of the things
that happened
that must have been surreal
for you -- I imagine many steps
of this were surreal --
but the January 6th committee
subpoenaed your film, like you
had interviews that, you know,
reflected different people's
state of mind about January 6th.
And because it was subpoenaed,
and because it turned up there,
you've been accused of
being a spy,
that you had sort of implanted
yourself in the campaign
for the purposes of this.
One, what was it like getting
subpoenaed in the first place?
And two, how have you reacted to
some of the conspiracy theories
about your involvement?
-I think I'm definitely
the first spy
ever to be on this show,
I think.
-Yeah.
-It's not exactly good --
-Well, I'll say this, you're
the first one who's admitted it.
[ Laughter ]
-Exactly. Exactly.
Exactly. Exactly.
No, I mean, the whole thing
has been completely surreal.
I mean, when you get the e-mail
with the subpoena attached that
says, you know, "Alex Holder,
you're hereby commanded to
appear, you know, in
the United States
House of Representatives,"
I mean, obviously it's a pretty,
you know, surreal experience.
And I think when I actually went
into the hearing and --
So, it's in a private room.
It's the same room that you see
on all the January 6th clips
they show.
And I was sort of pulling
the chair back,
and I was thinking like, "What
the [bleep] is going on?
I mean, this is absolutely
crazy.
I mean, honestly,
like it's just mad."
And then, yeah, I mean, I think
all the conspiracy theories that
have come out have also
been somewhat strange.
I'm an MI6 spy
and I'm an undercover FBI agent.
-Right.
-So, you know, I'm both sides.
-You wear a couple of
different hats,
and that's what everybody
respects about you as a spy.
[ Laughter ]
Very few people can do both.
The clip we showed where
the former president comes in
and he's very taken
with the floors --
He says, "Look at these floors."
That's at Mar-a-Lago,
so those are his floors.
-Yes. Yes.
[ Laughter ]
-And yet he seems very surprised
and delighted
by the quality of the floors.
Were they great-looking floors?
-No, they really weren't.
-Really? Okay.
[ Laughter ]
-I mean, Mar-a-Lago is actually
very beautiful.
And the room that we were in was
actually a really beautiful room
as well.
-It does genuinely look
beautiful on film. Yeah.
-But, I mean, the least most
beautiful thing
in the entire room
was the floor.
So, he walks in, I go,
"Hello, Mr. President."
And he completely ignores me and
then goes, "Look at this floor."
And I'm like, "What?"
Of all the things to look at,
I mean, there's this, like,
hideous painting of him from
like 30 years ago behind
that's like an oil painting,
which was, like,
the most eye-catching of
everything in there.
But, like, literally, the floor
of all the things.
Then he comes in, sits down,
and then we start having
a conversation about the last
time I'd interviewed him,
he was in the White House.
And he says, "Yeah, but this is
much nicer than the White House,
isn't it?"
I mean, that's the thing with
Trump -- everything that
he owns, everything that he
touches, everything that's got
his name on it is definitely
better than anything else.
-Yeah. Well you haven't lived
here as long,
but you might not know,
he's mentally ill.
Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
So that's -- that's what it is.
[ Cheers and applause ]
So, wait, you -- I do want to
say, I know that you went on
this journey where you thought
that he was lying about the fact
that he won the election,
but over the course of
these interviews, you've
actually come to believe
that he does believe that he had
this election stolen from him.
-He's bat[bleep] crazy, the guy.
I mean, there's no question.
[ Laughter ]
-But this was a journey
you took, right?
-Absolutely. I mean, the idea
that I would have had
a preconceived notion that he
really believed in his own lie
before I met him was something
that just is beyond
anything I could have
comprehended. Right?
I mean, this is the President of
the United States of America.
And when I interviewed him
for the first time,
you know,
he's in the White House,
all the apparatus of
the presidency is there.
The guy with
the nuclear football
is outside the room, right?
Secret Service is everywhere.
You know, "Mogul on the move."
That's his code name.
I mean,
it's all completely insane.
And he's looking me in the eye,
and he's telling me --
this is after his own
attorney general had said
there was no basis whatsoever
for any of the election
conspiracies that he was
still going on about
and still does go on about.
And so, he's looking me in
the eye, and he's telling me,
"There's no way Biden got
80 million votes
and we need to reopen all
the ballots in Georgia
to find these extra votes."
So, I mean, it was just crazy
because at the end of the day,
if the President of the United
States has come to believe in
his own lie, that's really scary
and terrifying.
And so I remember, like, after
he left, I sort of put my hand
on the wall, and I was like,
"Actually, I'm not going to
think about this now.
I'll wait until I get back to
the hotel"
'cause it was just too insane.
But yeah.
-I wonder how many times someone
has had, you know,
a private moment with the
president and then just
walked out and put their hand
on the wall...
[ Laughter ]
...and just, like, taking
a moment before going on with
the rest of their day.
I really, truly hope
you don't have to
make a sequel to this series.
[ Laughter ]
But I'm so glad you made
the first one. Thank you so much
for being here. It's really
a delight talking to you.
Alex Holder, everybody.
"Unprecedented" is streaming
on Discovery+.
We'll be right back with comedy
from Hoodo Hersi.